die zunehmende bedrohung durch
nordkoreas atom- und raketenprogramm
jetzt vermehrt die frage auf ob man sich
dagegen schützen oder zur wehr setzen
kann raketenabwehrsysteme kommen hier
immer öfter ins gespräch und wecken
erwartungen doch können sie diese
erwartungen auch erfüllen
[Musik]
ein blick auf die entwicklung von
raketen abwehrsystemen zur zeit des
kalten krieges also 1950 bis jetzt von
19 90 standen sich die sowjetunion und
die usa gegenüber beide seiten hatten
tausende von interkontinentalraketen man
konnte sich gegenseitig mehrfach
vernichten um einen gewissen schutz zu
haben einigte man sich darauf dass jeder
ein abo system installieren darf moskau
sollte geschützt werden auf sowjetischer
seite und raketensilos auf
amerikanischer seite
das führte auch zum abschluss des apm
vertrages 19 72 mit dem ende des kalten
krieges kamen eine neue dynamik wer hat
neue atommächte mit indien pakistan
china und gerade die anschläge die
terroranschläge von nine eleven von 2001
haben die usa
darin bekräftigt hier einen völlig neuen
ansatz gehen zu müssen
sie haben wir hier in weiterer folge in
abm vertrag gekündigt 2002 sie wollten
keinerlei einschränkungen mehr haben
beide gestaltung ihrer luftverteidigung
und ihre raketenabwehr
wie stellt sich die situation heute dar
die usa haben enorm in den aufbau eines
raketenabwehrsystems seines globalen
systems investiert sie wollen damit
einerseits mehr sicherheit haben
andererseits jede strategische
handlungsfähigkeit erhalten
sie stützen sie gab auf partner in der
region europa ist es der nato im
westpazifik südkorea und japan nordkorea
bekräftigt sie in ihrer auffassung dass
sie hier diesen raketenabwehrschirm
brauchen russland und china sehen das
kritisch weil diese leistungsfähigen
radarsysteme natürlich auch in ihrem
bereich hinein wirken können
sie sehen sich daher in ihrer
verteidigungs und abschreckungsfähigkeit
stark gemindert und lehnen diese systeme
somit ab wie kann man sich nun den
abfang
rakete vorstellen drei elemente kommen
hier zum zusammenwirken zuerst erkennen
des abschusses das sollen satelliten aus
dem weltall machen
in weiterer folge berechnung der
flugbahn vermutliches ziel das ist eine
aufgabe der sensoren insbesondere der
rathaus systeme und dann muss natürlich
drittens eine abfangrakete gestartet
werden
und die soll dann auch treffen
punktgenau viel zeit ist nicht zur
verfügung eine interkontinentalrakete
fliegt 20 minuten in etwa sie habe eine
geschwindigkeit von 24.000 km h
also macht 20 grob und die reaktionszeit
ist daher äußerst gering
dazu gibt es noch zusätzliche
herausforderungen wir haben heute kurz
mittel und langstrecken raketen mit
einer reichweite von 100 bis zu 10.000
km
wir haben mehrfach sprengköpfe die
identifiziert und bekämpft werden müssen
es können daten verschossen werden es
können elektronische störungen erfolgen
und es können sehr viele raketen
gleichzeitig abgeschossen werden wo es
sehr schwer wird dann jede einzelne zu
bekämpfen
man versucht dem zu begegnen durch ein
mehrschichtiges abwehrsystem wo eben
auch abfangraketen unterschiedlicher
reichweite zum zusammenwirken kommen die
sensorik wird natürlich immer mehr
verbessert die radarsysteme sind
wesentlich ausgereifter und man ist auch
bestrebt immer mehr auf schiffe diese
systeme zu verlagern weil die dann
weltweit konzentriert werden können sie
können verlagert werden
man ist flexibler man kann hier
militärische ausgedrückt schwergewichte
bilden
vor kurzem hat nordkorea eine
mittelstreckenrakete über japan hinweg
abgeschossen
viele haben sich gefragt warum japan
nicht versucht hat diese rakete
abzufangen
einige überlegungen
es war für japan relativ rasch klar dass
es nicht das zielgebiet war sondern dass
die rakete sind nicht gefährden würde
zum zweiten die gefahr eines
fehlschusses wäre natürlich wasser auf
die propaganda mühlen nordkoreas gewesen
es hätte aber auch eine interne
grundsatzdebatte über die sinn- und
zweckmäßigkeit des system hervorgerufen
und selbst tritt muss bei einem treffer
wäre sehr ungewiss gewesen wie ihr die
eskalation voranschreitet wie nordkorea
darauf reagiert hätte
wie kann es daher mit
raketenabwehrsystemen weitergehen ein
ausblick raketen habe es systeme sind
eine unglaubliche technische
herausforderung sie sind aber auch eine
sicherheitspolitische herausforderung
weil der eine sich sicher fühlen kann
vereinfacht ausgedrückt und andere
verunsichert sind wenn er dieses system
nicht hat und sein system der
abschreckung nicht mehr funktioniert das
kann wiederum zur aufrüstung maßnahmen
zu einer rüstungsspirale führen wir
haben aber andererseits bedrohungen wie
sie heute nordkorea darstellt aber auch
andere staaten vielleicht in der zukunft
oder akteure daher schon der berechtigte
wunsch ihre raketenabwehrsysteme
entsprechend voranzutreiben und
funktions tauglich zu machen
die einfachste lösung wäre sicher eine
lösung am verhandlungstisch arbeit zu
führen indem diese systeme überflüssig
werden
das ist aber angesichts der heutigen
geopolitischen spannungen keinesfalls zu
erwarten
zu erwarten ist vielmehr dass massiv in
diese systeme investiert wird egal um
welchen politischen oder ökonomischen
preis
[Musik]